16:45 and sol michael of russia is a bit
dead he was the first ruler of the
Romanov dynasty and oversaw a pretty
tumultuous time in Russia he was
succeeded by the young Alexis who left
most of the actual governing to a man
could Boris Moritz old who was a Boyer
what's a Boyer well they were high
ranking Nobles who had previously will
did immense power but were much reduced
since the Romanovs came to power Moritz
ah've was a competent if not corrupt
bureaucrat and he tried to raise more
money for the government more itself
would be thrown out of office by the
Tsar in 1648 after he raised taxes on
salt which caused a riot
so Russia at this point had one glaring
issue it was economically backwards it
was mostly backwards in things like
agriculture which had made immense
technical progress in other parts of
Europe like the Netherlands in England
in Russia however agriculture made no
progress in farming methods remain the
same since there were loads of peasants
and slaves to do the word in 1649 though
alexis issued a law code which freed all
of the agricultural slaves in russia and
then made them serfs he also sought to
give better to find legal status to the
agricultural peasants by making them
serfs serfdom being a serf was a
hereditary status which expressly tied
you to the land of your Lord previously
many peasants and slaves had fled their
Lords because agricultural work sucked
see in Russia a shortage of reasonable
land wasn't an issue because Russia is
huge it was labor that was valuable and
so preventing the movement of serfs
protected the wealth of the nobility and
of course the Tsar in terms of foreign
policy alexis was quite peaceful just
kidding in 1654 he invaded the
polish-lithuanian Commonwealth which was
suffering from its own instability the
Russians performed extremely well at
first and occupied most of the country
which was then invaded by the Swedish -
because why not
Poland Lithuania defeated the Swedish
and started to turn the tide but a civil
war broke out and financial ruin forced
them to sue for peace
Russia gained this territory including
the cities of Smolensk and Kiev the last
row of which was supposed to be only
temporary but fun fact no Alexis his
reign also saw religious reform
Alexis believed that Russia was being
punished because it was straying from
the correct religious path he thus
sought to reform church practices with
the help of the patriarch of Moscow
patriarchy nikan the head of the
Orthodox Church in Russia
this was unsurprisingly met with
resistance from those who considered the
changes to be too dramatic into Western
and by Western I mean that they were in
line with the Ukrainian and Greek
Orthodox Church is not like France or
something in 1668 - Synod was called to
formalize these changes those who
resisted these new practices were
excommunicate
became known as Old Believers these Old
Believers would represent a sizable
schism in the russian orthodox church
for many more centuries alexis also had
issues with revolt
one such revolt was led by a man could
stanker Rosina cossack who in 1670 had
captured the city of ceratin and was
pillaging literally everything a series
of peasant revolts coincided with this
and it took a year for the central
Moscow government to quell the uprisings
and eventually execute regime in 1676
alexis shook off his mortal coil and was
succeeded by his eldest son Fyodor who
was crowned Fyodor the third so the
young Fyodor was a good sponsor of the
church and sought to strengthen its
position whilst encouraging learning
across the Sodom this was pretty much
all he did since he died at the ripe old
age of 21 in 1682
this left two potential heirs to the
throne alexis his eldest surviving son
ivan from his first wife who was very
sickly and Peter the healthy son of his
second wife were the supporters of Peter
had him quickly proclaimed sour which
caused Ivan supporters to riot Ivan's
supporters were aided by the stroke see
the palace guard who stormed the royal
palace and basically murdered everyone
who had ever wronged them in the end it
was determined that both Ivan and Peter
would be Co rulers in the Ivan's sister
Sophia would act as regent for them both
during his youth Peter wasn't kept in
Moscow but sent to a place called Rio
Bridgend square where he developed a
love for the military and in particular
a fascination with ships and navies
Sofia who was aided by a man called for
sea legal it seemed rude throughout the
1680s with fair competence she signed
the Treaty of eternal peace with Poland
in 1686 which did two things one it
signed Russia up to an anti Ottoman
alliance and two demonstrated that
nobody knew what the term eternal meant
in 1689 Sophia came up with the great
idea let's cram in to pose the two czars
to the nobility in the strokes either
had supported her this was a step too
far and she was sent away to a convent
for the rest of her life
this left both Ivan and Peter as joint
rulers but since Ivan was unable to rule
this made Peter the primary Tsar
although it was his mother who was
really in charge in 216 94 when she came
down with a case of the deads
two years later Ivan also tied meaning
that all of Russia was finally Peters
the first thing that Peter or Peter the
first did with his newfound freedom was
what all great Russian leaders would do
thereafter invade the Ottoman Empire
Russia was already at war with the
Ottomans as part of an alliance but
Peter made sure that there was a renewed
effort at taking southern territory they
saw Russia gained this territory as of
which importantly gave it access to the
see in the south so pita was a very
involved leader who took great pride in
personally overseeing government reforms
and projects for example in 1697 he
launched what is called the grand
embassy this was where his diplomats
traveled around Europe securing new
military technology and know-how as well
as strengthening the alliance against
the Ottoman Empire he traveled with this
embassy personally although for the most
of it he was in disguise he travelled to
many countries across Europe gaining
valuable information but had no luck
with fighting the Ottomans his grand
embassy had to be cut short when the
strokes he started to revolt in Moscow
this was put down before pita even
returned to Russia but afterwards all of
those involved was severely punished
Peter had a strong distaste for the
muscovite way of life ie he disliked
many of the old ways of doing things he
took on a more European Way of dress and
abandoned the forbids the previous
Russian leaders and the boyars had
sported you could opt not to but then
you'd have to pay a beard tax Peter
oversaw a simplification of the Russian
alphabet banned arranged marriages and
also changed the Russian calendar to the
julian 1 so whilst travelling across
Europe Peter had learned a great deal
about navies how they operate and how to
build them the problem for Peter was
that he needed access to a better coast
the Baltic one specifically one issue it
was controlled by the Swedish Empire
Peter thus made an alliance with Denmark
and Saxony his leader was also the ruler
of the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth
against Sweden together they invaded and
so began the great northern war Denmark
near immediately withdrew from the war
allowing Sweden to turn east undeterred
Peter clash with the Swedish at the 1700
battle of Narva where he was completely
crushed by the better trained and
equipped Swedish forces Sweden hereafter
turned its attention to Saxony in the
Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth which
gave peat at the chance to regroup he
subsequently pushed into the lands of
ingria and Livonia and took this
territory to keep these territorial
gains Peter constructed a fort here and
founded a settlement in 1703 st.
Petersburg over the next four years
Sweden managed to stomp Saxony in the
Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth and in
1707 its army advanced into Russia like
so many others in history the invasion
was difficult because winter rolled
around and winter in Russia is very very
cold
Swedish forces retreated down south and
Peter followed where they clashed at the
Battle of Poltava here the Swedish army
was decisively beaten Charles the 12th
fled to the Ottoman Empire and his army
surrendered shortly afterwards
Peter demanded that the Ottomans hand
Charles over which they said no to and
so more war fortunately for Russia
Denmark and Poland Lithuania had
re-entered the
war unfortunately for Russia the Ottoman
army was incredibly formidable and
Peter's recent gains down south were
lost in 1711 the year after this defeat
Peter made a monumental decision he
moved the capital of the Sodom from
Moscow to st. Petersburg because again
he didn't care for the old ways even
though he was at war Peter still wish to
reform his kingdom but there were many
opponents to this reform not least was
his son an heir to the throne Alexis
Alexis had been raised by some boyars
many of whom resented Peters reforms and
he grew up to despise his father when in
1716 Peter wanted Alexis to join him on
campaign alexis fled to Austria which
made Peter look pretty bad in 1718
Alexis returned after his father had
agreed that he wouldn't be punished and
shortly after this Peter had Alexis
tortured to death for embarrassing him
Peter then changed the rules of
succession from my nearest relative gets
it to I get to pick who's next
beyond filicide Peter had introduced
widespread modernizing reforms in areas
like justice religion and of course the
military in terms of Justice Peter
banned lawyers from courtrooms because
and I'm not kidding here they talk too
much judges also weren't permitted to
make new rulings because in Peters
Russia only legislators could interpret
law and there was only one legislator
Peter as for the military Peter is often
seen as the founder of the Russian Navy
by 1720 Russia's Baltic Fleet was larger
than the entire Swedish Navy this was
quite impressive considering that in
1710 Russia didn't have a single naval
vessel in terms of religious reform
Peter decided in 1721 to abolish the
position of patriarch of Moscow and
replace it with the Holy Synod this was
basically a Council of men whom he could
bully into doing what he wanted 1721 was
a pretty big year for both Peter and
Russia first of all the great northern
war ended in a Russian victory so Russia
gained all of this territory having
control over this Russia's position in
Europe and that of Peter was much more
prestigious as such Peter decided that
his title of Tsar wasn't fancy enough
and he declared his no title to be
Imperato or Emperor and the Sodom of
Russia was now the Russian Empire in
1722 Peter created his table of ranks
whereby people's rank in society was
ideally no longer to be determined by
birth but now how useful they were they
saw many sons of boyars lose favor and
some new men ie nobly born people who
worked for the government rise up the
ranks Peter in 1723 also freed all of
the household slaves in Russia and made
them serfs Peter's transformative reign
would come to an end in 1725
he died and so it was time for his
appointed heir to take over oh wait he
didn't pick one and so decades of
succession disputes and turmoil which
culminated in Catherine the Great but
that's for another time
so Peter the Great's legacy is
undeniably important but also deeply
complex and controversial his reign
which only happened because the stars
align took Russia from being a kingdom
on the other side of the
polish-lithuanian Commonwealth to an
empire that nobody could ignore he laid
the foundations for Russia's rise to
great power status and deprived that
same status from Sweden he was
responsible for many sensible reforms
and modernized the Russian system of
government society religion and warfare
changed under his stewardship and so
it's no wonder that be seen as the
epitome of the enlightened despot one
who could bring Russia a great deal of
glory and ultimately someone who was
willing to kill his own son to protect
that glory I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching and a
special thanks to Thomas guest rich Adam
Harvey Winston Cawood and James
Bissonnette if you'd like to learn more
about Peter the Great in the Russian
Empire there are some book
recommendations in the description below
you